welcome see them won in spanish
how are you
bye very very excited
we are very excited looking
forward to you is celebrating several things one
of them that caught my attention is your
30th anniversary 30 songs 30 duets
tell us a little more about that
look what an achievement it is  Jorge
very important Mexican music is very
important within music because you
never
knowingly expect that it
has been done before on a record
where more than 30 artists came together to
support someone it is no anger
an iconic career that you have had and
are  we live las vegas this
weekend as it says the second year in a
row you can tell these
fans these fans that will be
going to your concert this saturday that they are going
to enjoy a great show a great
show in las vegas we really
care about  doing something very big
and very very good for me is not
just a dance for which it is a
presumed important wait  We are
waiting for someone to accompany you
on stage, one of these artists
suddenly companies us,
so for those who are going to perform
at the concert,
expect surprises from you.
it is the toads of the
planet hollywood there i come to las
vegas next this coming saturday 11 september 11